e
de l'armée de la région de, , ,n
Ar C C C Ce qui est surprenant,
c'est que la sirène d'alerte m t
ntntntntion. On s'habitue.
D'autant plus surprenanturururué
lancés sur la ville.eeeeeeeeeeee
celui qui a détruit une usineets
ont affirmé qu'elle contenait
de l'armement de l'OTAololololot
une aluminerie désaffectée.
des armements! Il ne resterait
rien."
Comme les Russes ont d'énormes
pertes, ils n'arasasasasas à
percer, alors ils s'attaquent
à l'infrastructure civile.
prédire que les Russes vont
perdrererererere.
"Leur armée prendra la même
direction que leur bateau,
elle va couler".
Une im
ukrainienne répand. On voit ici
le Ktrtrtrtrtrtrain de couler,
comme le croiseur Moskva.
pas fait de dommages, mais e e e
chez notre interprète.
- Le bruit éta
troisisisisisisision. Pour la
première fois, je ne sais pas
comm
pas de parole pour expliquer
laa a a a a a a ressentie.
- Zaporijjeseseseseseses villes
clés les plus importantes
pour les
franchir le grand fleuve Dniepr
et progresser vers le no
l'ouest. Raison de plus pour
que les Ukrainiens la défendent
La ville n'est qu'à 30 km
du front et undsdsdsdsdsdsds
problèmes, c'est l'afflux de
réfugiés en provenance, entre
martyre.
Dès ler r r r r r r de la
guerre, un groupe de jeunes de
la v
une organisation d'entraide
E E E E E E Elle commence
avec un centre d'appel qui trie
Le théâtre des jeunes s'est
transforméenenenenenenenentrepôt
où des volontaires recueillent
et ens
matériel et tous les produits et
obje, , , , , , , , d'abord aux
soldats et ensuite aux réfugiés.
Ici, c'est la pharmacie, gérée
avec, au fond, les produitsieie.
Les vêtements, la nourriture,
systématiquement, rien n'estilis
venus de Grande-Bretagne, mais
aussi d'Israël et d'Espagne,
deux gros donateurs,
et d'Allemagne.
"La communauté ukrainienne
du Canada contribue beaucoup",
dit Constantin, le cerveau
de cette organisation
spectaculaire.
"C'est très compliqué, dit-il.
On a automatisé le processus
avec un système de réceptionetes
rapide et efficace."
Ce qui lui manque?
Des sous-vêtements, des
t-shirts, des produits d'hygiène
et le transport pour évacuer
les ututututututututut, pas de
vêtements, ils en ont reçu trop.
Ici, on fabrique aussi
des filets de camouflage
pour l'armée en quantité
industrielle. m m m m m m m m me
restaurant Jobs, les cuisiniers
et assistants, tous bénévoles,
préparent des repas pourl'l'l'ls
restaurants en ville et des
centaines dans tout le pays
font la même chose.
"Au début de
dit Maxime, on préparait
1000 repas par jour. On a réduit
à 450, mais on livre seulement
aux so
Il a besoin de plus de produits
alimentaires et de volontaires.
L'après-midi, Jobs redevient
Ce genre de mobilisation
spontanée s'est faite dès
le premier jour à l'échellekrkr.
Ici Jean-Michel Leprince,
Radio-Canada, Zaporijji